now we have patreon what question
questions and then we don't know we're
not doing on a helpful advice I have one
on hold on okay so just answer if you
can this is from our friend Sean failure
my god mo Collins I grew up in a cult a
real cult not a crystal a occult and me
and my brother would sneak MADtv at risk
of religious flogging and laugh
hilariously at Lorraine my question is
where did most source these characters
language what did you scold he is part
of a cult
well religious vlog i source them
Lorena's an amalgamation of many women
up in minnesota which you could then
broaden and say midwest and the thing
about Lorraine is you know the uh-huh
for instance is a it's a mechanism that
I've really felt people up there used
when they're just it's almost like in
ellipses it's sort of to let the other
person know we don't have anything to
talk about we're not getting into deep
things cuz they don't up there it's just
basic like you know here's his bottle
[Laughter]
just it's keeping the music of a
conversation going where there isn't
necessarily a lot of notes and that's
sort of a Midwestern thing so that's
where she but curiosity lots of
curiosity you know but conversation it
was Lorraine something that like when
you came to LA you already had or you
had written up years before I actually
Lorraine I used to do with a friend of
mine in Minnesota there was a there were
Lorraine had a counterpart by my friend
Melissa Denton and we just it was these
two women that would go shopping we
write sketches and do them at a thing
called balls which is a midnight show
and on the weekends in Minneapolis and
yes they just like had conversations
with each other like mmm-hmm it was I
don't even know how we would really to
be honest when I auditioned at MADtv I
had to change Lorraine a little bit to
put her into the format so Lorraine
became like this I I did my audition
with Loreen was her you know sitting on
the porch talking about the colored
people that moved in next door
yeah up at the lake
but that's that Minnesota it's it's a
it's Minnesota racism but but that's not
who the rain ended up being on the show
and I'm actually really glad of that
she's just a curious figure right we
have another one from gegen sing what's
her name gengan sing all right beautiful
name this had the most likes so when
asked this one what was your immediate
reaction when you heard Bobby farted and
krysta Flanagan's mouth well this is the
first I'm hearing that why do I you know
I farted in crista Flanagan smell it was
gonna be love farted in my mouth getting
splattered in the story what we'll see
this is this is after I was gone
correct yes all hell breaks loose
without fart in her mouth okay she knew
yogurt well I didn't know she was you
didn't know hello it's nice to meet
what no no I don't know what she was but
I thought she was like an accent or
something but I grabbed the back of her
head while she's eating yogurt and her
mouth was open to eat yogurt I saw her
mouth relationship after that not good I
had to get a lawyer
juju yeah you had to get a lawyer but
nothing happened because and then I had
a conversation with her no I said I used
to this kind of behavior and then you
went and pooped on the table right
octopus has that what ink think that he
does it's yours yep pullings mine
thank you everybody does it
yep but I just we don't fart in people's
mouths Bobby okay
no we don't so I did are you okay look
at me in the eye you need to tell he has
a fascination for the smell of poop okay
so we all have things do things I think
this scent it's the one thing that
actually works in our relationship
there's dog if a dog has an accident in
the house yeah I'll get it about it I
don't know I just like the fascination I
like horrible smelling thing do you
really yeah yeah constantly but if it's
like you know you know in and out you
know the smells in and out I won't be
like I wouldn't be good like Detective
where I'd walked into a room there was a
homicide in the summer and the body's
been sitting in there for like five
months running away and that smell I
wouldn't be able to do that okay little
glimpses of poo
fine his in fact that's my throat
special yeah
[Music]